it started simple our money was sucked
up monthly or yearly for a newspaper or
magazine subscription and for a video
streaming subscription and for a music
subscription but now it seems there's no
object or thing that doesn't seem to
come with a money sucking subscription
attached yes it's getting out of hand
more and more of your money is going to
monthly and yearly subscriptions for all
types of things and they're only going
to be more subscriptions coming
especially from the gadgets and things
around you here's why and what you can
do to clean up your subscription list
[Music]
there are two reasons companies
everywhere have turned to charging us on
a monthly or yearly basis technology and
money allow me to use my internet
connected ring doorbell
to illustrate the technology part it's
always streaming video to my phone and
being updated with new features thanks
to the cloud if I want to see recordings
of what's happened in the past say
catching some crazy with a vacuum in
front of my house
ring asks that I pay $3 a month it's
what the tech industry refers to as SAS
or software as a service and yes even
pass hardware as a service the whole
thing is always updating and working for
you until you stop paying as more and
more things connect to the Internet
they'll come with subscriptions everyone
from router makers to workout equipment
companies are doing it why not charge a
flat fee these companies and Wall Street
love the idea of recurring revenue they
can expect a certain amount every month
or year from a set number of people and
they bank literally on the fact that we
often don't cancel yes it's real easy to
forget what we're paying for
and what subscriptions we have in fact
84% of Americans underestimate what they
pay monthly for subscriptions so here's
what we're all going to do
now number one make a list of your
subscriptions log into your credit card
or bank accounts and then make a good
old-fashioned list of the things you get
charged for every month and the amount
you pay services like trim and true bill
will do this for you
but I'm personally not a fan of allowing
other services access to my bank account
number to cancel the ones you don't use
I got back $20 a month by canceling two
subscriptions I was rarely using some
companies make cancelling easier than
others thanks to a 2018 California law
that required a way to cancel
subscriptions online companies have made
this a lot easier still be strong when
trying to cancel if you have difficulty
try those customer service chat box it
can be quite helpful for getting money
back ok maybe not that helpful if you've
subscribed to a service through Apple's
App Store canceling is a lot easier on
the iPhone go to settings tap iTunes and
App Store then tap your Apple ID then
view Apple ID then tap subscriptions and
cancel from there number 3 set a
calendar reminder to do this on a yearly
basis put it in your calendar right now
because this is just the start of the
madness especially if you like me
sometimes fall prey to that free trial
that silently becomes a recurring
monthly charge believe me the money is
going to start to be sucked from places
you never expected
[Music]
nobody was lost or harmed in the making
of this video